foreign
[Music]
not knowing is not a shame not asking is
a shame
the fruits of the tree fall at its roots
[Music]
a fool dreams of wealth a wise man of
happiness
[Music]
ability is not a school
the devil tempts all people but idle
people tempt the devil
[Music]
He Who falls by himself never cries
man is harder than iron stronger than
Stone but more fragile than a rose
[Music]
he who has no food has no power
he passes wisdom remains
foreign
with you will gossip about you
[Music]
what quickly flares up quickly goes out
the fly is small but big enough to make
you sick
[Music]
he who seeks a perfect friend is left
friendless
Prophet is the brother of loss
[Music]
one eats the other looks this is how
revolutions are born
close your eyes in the company of the
blind
[Music]
measure a thousand times cut once
a heart in love with beauty never grows
old
[Music]
what a man endures is the punishment of
his tongue
time is the medicine of every ill
[Music]
save the hay it's time will come
keep a thing seven years and you'll find
a use for it
[Music]
never put off till tomorrow what you can
do today
[Music]
the one who stays the last is left for
the frost
[Music]
the one who Rises early succeeds
the early bird catches the worm
[Music]
while there's life There's Hope
before the sun rises a lot of things
rise
[Music]
tell me who you go with and I'll tell
you who you are
[Music]
a real friend is understood even on a
bad day
don't trust wealth you would fall into
poverty
[Music]
do not trust your friend they will fill
your skin with hay
the one who gives the money Blows the
Whistle
money attracts money
doesn't grow on trees
wisdom doesn't always come with age
[Music]
always happens
fear a stupid friend not a smart enemy
is more difficult to speak to an
ignorant person than to get a camel over
a ditch
whatever will be will be
the neighbor's chicken seems like a
goose to the neighbor
the one who is burnt by hot milk blows
on yogurt before eating it
gold doesn't rust
free vinegar tastes sweeter than honey
the most successful fruitful
hard-working people always receive
criticism and jealousy
[Music]
you must give away your hand to gain a
goose
[Music]
sharp quick tempered people ultimately
cause harm to themselves
the bitterness of an onion is known not
by the one who eats it but by the one
who cuts it
[Music]
work breeds prosperity
love is like a nest of sparrows once
destroyed it can no longer be rebuilt
there is a lesson in all misfortune
you cannot stare at these two things the
Sun and death
[Music]
good words will open iron gates
many ants kill a camel
[Music]
two captains sink a ship
you should be the master of those who do
not love you and the slave of those who
love you
[Music]
there is no mountain without fog in the
same way there is no man of Merit
without slander
patience is the key to Paradise
a fighter is never defeated if he does
not Tire a fighting again
the sea never buys fish
when two jars collide one breaks
[Music]
a single Advantage is worth a thousand
sorceries
[Music]
a liar's house is on fire but no one
believes him
a hungry dog will bring a lion down
[Music]
he who has power in his hands has no
need to lie he uses violence
[Music]
a true word needs no oath
he who speaks truth must have one foot
in the stirrup
[Music]
he who has no children has one sorrow
he who has children has a thousand
sorrows
[Music]
when violence comes into the house law
and justice leave through the chimney
If You Weep For All the sorrows in this
world in the end you will have no eyes
a man will sacrifice his head to conquer
a heart
[Music]
a woman has advice only for another
woman
foreign
don't speak sweet words when your Deeds
are of stone
[Music]
nothing works unless you want it to work
the dog that is going to bite does not
show its teeth
[Music]
Cox said Crow too early will quickly
find themselves in the pot
one night with an ugly woman and one day
in the mountains are both like an
eternity
if the bald man knew a remedy he would
rub it on his own head
if your guest becomes a cook your Larder
will soon be empty
[Music]
the thief can lie those he has stolen
from cannot
the father donated a Vineyard to his son
the son didn't give a single bunch of
grapes to his father
abundance is from activity
a horse can die from too much barley
[Music]
two watermelons cannot be held under one
arm
having two ears and one tongue we should
listen twice as much as we speak
the bride who brings a Golden Throne
will sit on it herself
honey is one thing the price another
fall into a river hang on to a snake
when God wants to please a poor man
he lets him lose his donkey and then
helps him find it again
[Music]
the world is like this one gives a melon
the other gets stomach cramps
[Music]
no matter how far you have traveled on a
wrong road turn back
you can State the truth in a friendly
way
the eagle does not feed on flies
[Music]
The Physician prescribes the medicine
the vulture waits for the body
[Music]
where there are no sheep they call the
goat princess
Crystal
when it shines the most it soon cracks
one bad experience is worth more than a
thousand threats
he who asks for alms blushes once he who
refuses twice
[Music]
The Raven sees its chickens as Falcons
for those in love Baghdad is near
Istanbul
don't say Amen to an unacceptable prayer
foreign
too big of a miser is to dig a trench in
the sea
whose faith is to be hanged will not
drown
the bear knows seven songs all about
honey
the buyer of rotten beans is a blind man
[Music]
God made low branches for birds that
cannot fly so well
[Music]
he ran away from the rain and was caught
in a hail storm
you cannot Forge a good sword from Bad
iron
when a rich man falls they say it was an
accident when a poor man falls they say
he was drunk
no flock without a dog and Shepherd
if a stone falls on an egg it is bad for
the egg
if an egg falls on the stone it is still
bad for the egg
everyone admires their own character
do not leave to the morning the business
of the evening
[Music]
a horse knows his rider by his Spurs
judge the linen by the hymn the Girl by
the mother
people who make the most or the loudest
threats are the least likely to take
action
too much Sympathy for the unfortunate
makes you unhappy
better an enemy you recognize than a
friend you don't
[Music]
your five-year-old son is your
instructor at 10 he is your slave at 15
you're equal and after that either
Friend or Foe
foreign
[Music]
blood away with blood but with water
heaven was inspired by the first judge
to take a bribe
the first drink makes you a frisky
gazelle the second an impetuous zebra
the third a roaring lion
and the fourth a silly donkey
[Music]
a knife wound heals a wound caused by
words does not
[Music]
where you were born is less important
than how you live
you may lie but not too much
[Music]
he who knows much makes many mistakes
if a cat wants to eat her kittens she'll
say that they look like mice
[Music]
it matters less to a person where they
are born than where they can live
[Music]
being overly careful invites misfortunes
cruelty is stupidity
sorrow is to the soul what a worm is to
Wood
[Music]
there are many words that are like
salted Jam
the fool castrates himself so he can
accuse his pregnant wife of adultery
[Music]
gold that is Lent goes away laughing and
comes back in tears
[Music]
death is the black camel that kneels
before every door
like it or not men fall in love with
women who are not afraid to leave them
even the thinnest piece of meat will
happily marry a piece of bread
[Music]
he who kisses the feet of his mother
kisses the steps of paradise
[Music]
God postpones he does not overlook
a friend is one soul in two bodies
[Music]
if the lady of the house breaks
something it is an unfortunate accident
if the servant does it is a disaster
he who lives on Hope dies of starvation
[Music]